إنه وقت عصيب بالنسبة لهذه
المزارع الكينية التي فقدت أكثر من نصف محاصيلها في
وقت سابق من هذا العام ، والسبب في هطول الأمطار الغزيرة
على المناخ هذا العام
وهطول الأمطار ، وبالتالي فإن المحاصيل لم تكن
جيدة.
زراعة المحاصيل من الذرة إلى
الأفوكادو وجوز المكاديميا ، هذه
المحاصيل في مزرعتها التي تقل
مساحتها عن فدان واحد أو ما تعتمد عليه في كسب
لقمة العيش ،
العديد من أنواع الأفوكادو ،
مزرعة Goose الجديدة هي واحدة من العديد من الأنواع التي
تضررت بشدة من الظروف الجوية القاسية
خلال  العامين الماضيين ولكن هناك
منظمة واحدة تأمل في تغيير
أن العمل الذي يقوم به صندوق فدان واحد في
كينيا كان يساعد المزارعين من خلال
تحسين عائداتهم
وسبل عيشهم وإمكانية وصولهم إلى المدخلات عالية الجودة
الموجودة في قلب نيروبي.
فرصة استعارة المواد الزراعية
من المعدات إلى البذور
بينما يساعدهم ذلك على زراعة محاصيلهم
بكفاءة وبيعها لتحقيق ربح أعلى.
تمتد التفويضات إلى ما وراء المجتمع المحلي فقط ،
ويهدف صندوق فدان واحد إلى توفير أكثر من
مليار دولار من التأثير بحلول عام 2030
للمزارعين أصحاب الحيازات الصغيرة في جميع أنحاء إفريقيا ،
وهو هدف طموح ستتم
مناقشته في المؤتمر السابع والعشرين لهذا العام والذي
سيعقد في منتجع الشاطئ المصري.
من charmele Sheikh بينما
يهدف صندوق فدان واحد إلى تحقيق تأثير بقيمة مليار دولار
بحلول عام 2030 لمساعدة صغار المزارعين
في إفريقيا ، سيقوم 27 من قادة العالم بالبناء على
تعهد أوسع تم التعهد به في
العام الماضي 26.100 مليار دولار
تم تخصيصها للبلدان النامية
مثل  تلك الموجودة في أفريقيا ولكن لم يتم الوفاء
بها مائة مليار دولار لا
تحل المشكلة ولكنها تظهر التزامًا من
الدول المتقدمة
وتبني الثقة وتضمن للدول
النامية أن هناك جدية في
تزويدها
بالموارد المالية اللازمة لجعلها عادلة.
المساهمات في الجهود العالمية
لمكافحة تغير المناخ في
حين أن هذا الجهد العالمي سوف يستغرق الكثير
للمشاركة  يأكلون أنه سيكون فدانًا واحدًا في
المرة الأولى للمشاركة في إعطاء صوت
لمن لا صوت لهم ، وآمل جدًا
أن نرى المزيد من التنفيذ
بعد الشرطي 27 هذا العام لأنه
لأول مرة
تم الاعتراف بصغار المزارعين الذين يتعرفون
على هؤلاء  تضررت بشدة من تغير المناخ
في خلق الأموال لمساعدة أصحاب الحيازات الصغيرة من
المزارعين مثل Nagu بعض هؤلاء CNN
[موسيقى] أو
الأجانب